Setting Fire to Glass - Chlorine Trifluoride
First discovered back in the 1930s, chlorine
trifluoride is a rather curious chemical that
easily reacts, sometimes explosively, with
just about every known substance on Earth.
Just to get the ball rolling, here’s a few
of the more unusual things chlorine trifluoride
is known to set fire to on contact: glass,
sand, asbestos, rust, concrete, people, pyrex,
cloth, and the dreams of children…
Obviously the first question to answer here
is how chlorine trifluoride is somehow able
to cause asbestos, a substance that is known
for being almost completely fire retardant,
to catch on fire.
Well, that’s because chlorine trifluoride
is a more powerful oxidizing agent by mass
than oxygen itself.
Meaning it’s capable of rapidly oxidizing
things that would normally be considered practically
“impossible” to set aflame, like asbestos.
Chlorine trifluoride is such an effective
oxidizer that it can even potentially set
fire to things that have seemingly already
been burned up, like ash or spent charcoal.
The substance is so highly reactive that famously
unreactive elements like platinum, osmium
and iridium will begin to corrode when they
come into contact with it.
Notably tough elements like titanium and tungsten
are also regarded as being wholly unsuitable
to storing the chemical because they set on
fire as soon as they come into contact with
it.
The only known way to store chlorine trifluoride
“safely”, which we use in the loosest
possible sense, is to put it inside of a sealed
containers made of steel, iron, nickel or
copper which are able to contain the chemical
safely if they’re first treated with flourine
gas.
This is because doing so will coat the metal
in a thin fluoride layer, with which the chemical
won’t react.
However, if this layer is compromised in anyway,
or the metal isn’t completely dry, chlorine
trifluoride will begin to react violently
and cause the vessel to explode.
A few of the other things known to not react
with chlorine trifluoride include nitrogen,
the inert gases and polychlorotrifluoroethylene.
Rather fortunately, chlorine trifluoride doesn’t
react with air unless it happens to contain
a larger than average amount of water vapor.
Speaking of which, when chlorine trifluoride
comes into contact with water, it will react
explosively with it and as a fun byproduct
creates large amounts of dangerous gasses
such as hydrofluoric acid and hydrochloric
acid.
Hydrofluric acid in particular is incredibly
dangerous and along with being able to melt
things like glass and concrete, can permanently
damage your lungs and eyes.
As if that wasn’t worrying enough, if you’re
ever unlucky enough to get hydrofluric acid
on your skin, it doesn’t actually hurt until
a few hours later.
After it has absorbed a bit, it starts destroying
your nerves and bones and can ultimately cause
cardiac arrest when it gets into your blood
stream.
In fact, in 1994 a lab technician in Australia
accidentally spilled hydrofluric acid on his
lap and despite immediately executing safety
procedures including hosing off, immersing
himself in a swimming pool, and later extensive
medical care (including needing to have one
of his legs amputated), within two weeks of
the accident, he was dead.
Unsurprisingly, the Nazis were really interested
in the military applications of chlorine trifluoride.
After all, it’s a substance that reacts
explosively with water (humans are largely
bags of water), and for those that don’t
come in contact with it directly, there’s
the byproduct of the deadly gasses.
Further, there is really little one can do
to put out the fires it causes directly other
than to let them burn off.
If you throw water on the source of the problem,
it will get worse.
The reaction here also doesn’t require atmospheric
oxygen to burn, so trying to use that method
of fire suppression won’t work either.
Though chlorine trifluoride was thankfully
never used during combat, the Nazis did succeed
in creating several tons of the stuff in a
secret facility known as the Falkenhagen Bunker
before it was captured by the Russians in
1944.
The Nazis working in the Falkenhagen Bunker
referred to chlorine trifluoride simply as
“Substance N” or “N-Stoff” and were
planning to store it inside specially designed
shells which could be used in battle.
According to reports released by the Soviets
following WW2, Nazi trials involving substance
N were promising.
But, of course, the weapon was incredibly
dangerous for those carrying it around too,
not just those they launch it at.
As an example of the kind of devastation chlorine
trifluoride can have, you only need to consider
what happened when almost a ton of this stuff
was accidentally spilled inside of a warehouse
in the 1950s.
According to eyewitness reports, the chemical
burned straight through a foot of concrete
and three feet of gravel while simultaneously
releasing a deadly cloud of gas containing
a cocktail of “chlorine trifluoride, hydrogen
fluoride, chlorine and hydrogen chloride”
that corroded every surface it came into contact
with.
After reading this you’re probably curious
about what possible purpose this chemical
could serve that doesn’t involve trying
to recreate a scene from a Michael Bay movie.
Well, due to the fact that chlorine trifluoride
is such a great oxidizer, there have been
several attempts to use it as a low-cost,
lightweight rocket fuel, starting with the
Nazis who tried to use it to propel torpedoes.
Of course, it’s so difficult to store safely
that it’s generally considered not to be
worth the risk for this usage.
After all, while you’d need to use less
fuel thanks to its extreme oxidizing capabilities,
if you had a rocket accident, you’d potentially
be spewing tons of this stuff all over the
place with no real effective way to deal with
the situation.
For instance, after studying and experimenting
with this chemical for rocket use, rocket
scientist Dr. John D. Clark famously said
about the best way to deal with potential
chlorine trifluoride rocket accidents- “I
have always recommended a good pair of running
shoes.”
There are a couple other useful applications
though.
For instance, it’s great for plasmaless
cleaning of certain surfaces used in semiconductor
manufacturing and it also works well at cleaning
uranium residue off of the walls of nuclear
power plants and removing built up oxides.